jordan
we're gonna jump straight into magnus's
game when this one finishes it looks
like eric
is winning
is it hard for eric now to sort of guide
it to that win or is this just about
jordan
finding ah this is talking about jordan
just simply playing out his frustration
and uh yeah eric's body language is
pretty relaxed there he knows he's
winning he can do anything he doesn't
need to rush even he can just slowly
bring the white king
maybe maybe jordan's just thinking how
he can uh dodge the interviewer you know
that you know i've seen duda just you
know like a bit like what's it british
bulldog there's this game bit like rugby
where you're playing the playgrounds and
you've got to you know get to the other
side of the pitch and dodge them i want
to you know maybe thinking do i go left
when i get to the interview and then go
right because i really don't want to
speak to anyone after this so i'm going
to get to my room and there we go and he
just runs off jordan from forest he
resigns game three but he is still in
the lead eric hanson making a comeback
he still has to win game four the